this album has been very warmly received
yeah it has were you surprised in any
way by that
no
I wouldn't have been surprised if it
came and went yeah
when I'm working on something and I uh
I feel
passionate about it it wouldn't surprise
me if others feel the same way but
an example of that would be when I was
making Graceland yeah I thought this is
I just love this but and as as it turned
out other people loved it but it
couldn't have said in advance well
there's just a Hunger for South African
music yes combined with American culture
it didn't exist but it but it did
satiate some Hunger on the other hand
when I made the Cape May on the show
that I that that briefly
made its run on Broadway
I also thought this is very interesting
this is a really interesting combination
of musical styles but
but no it didn't it didn't resonate in
the same way so I'm not surprised that
that this was accepted I wouldn't have
been surprised if people
ignored it yeah
um you've talked about this a little bit
I know but
this came to you in a dream
partly yeah it did
I uh you know I can show you that you
might find this interesting
on the January 15
2019 I had this dream the dream was said
you're working on
a piece called seven songs or you should
start working on this piece ghost I know
the dream was so vivid that I woke up
and wrote it down I don't usually it's
not like lines of songs that have never
come to me in dreams they have but this
was so vivid that I got up and wrote it
down seven Psalms and the PS was because
the Psalms had the PS and the
and then it was like a note to myself
Psalms of David so I didn't even know
really what was a Psalm you know when
something as Vivid as that happens
what do you make of it
I think it's worth uh you know it's
worth paying attention to it yeah to me
it was
significant enough that I that I wrote
it down so that to make sure I wouldn't
forget it by the next morning yeah and
what when I thought of it the next day I
I went to the Bible and I looked up the
Psalms of David and I thought I I don't
I don't think I'll be writing this
you know
um I don't know what I'll be writing I
don't know what this is about
but uh since it came to me in a dream
with someone or something's telling me
to do this I said well look it's not my
idea anyway so I'll just wait
until uh to this clarification of what
I'm supposed to do did you get
clarification yeah uh yeah it did come
as guitar pieces
not words but guitar and we were in
covid like you know isolation lockdown
so it was
that first lockdown was was a really
uh a fortuitous event for a lot of
artists I think because every everything
got quiet you're by yourself
and nothing was going on in the in the
world other than this so
so the guitar pieces started to come
and they came
uh
pretty freely for about a year and I
almost had
seven pieces
and then I started to get
uh words and phrases and dreams again
yeah and they would come like
two three times a week between three and
five A.M
and I would just write them down
and so I said okay this is just one of
those experiences
that I guess I've had throughout my life
where
something
I don't want to use a cliche but I'll
have to I'll go to the cliche where
you're a conduit you feel like some
piece of information is coming through
you
and you are expressing it but it's not
of you it's just through you yeah no I
mean that's a kind of a cliche
but it happens to be you know a
description of what happened in the in
this case did you did you ask yourself
in as this was happening where is this
coming from
not really because uh
I don't think there's an answer to it
where it's coming from and looking back
over my life as a as a writer when I
wrote The Sound of Silence and I was 23
years old that was probably the same
kind of phenomenon but at the time I
just thought oh
this is a kind of my best song at the
moment you know and the same thing with
Bridge Over Troubled Water where I
thought hmm
better than my usual this is good yeah
by the time I was
writing and this happened during
Graceland I I recognized that this was
something that something that
occasionally happens when it does
you pay attention to it and you try to
capture it and nourish it and and look
at it for whatever it is but
what is the source of creativity we
don't we don't know I don't even know if
I want to know it's just it's there
I'm grateful for it it's been there for
my most of my life at a certain point I
can become
I can apply a craft of songwriting to it
I can be an editor and say this is good
this would go here this is unnecessary
yeah but first there has to be a bulk of
information before it can be the editor
yeah I mean editing is delightful yeah
this I don't like this but I do like
this it's giving me a bunch of choices
I'll tell you which are my favorite but
look at a blank page
no no that's intimidating yeah
you'd said a few years back you weren't
planning on writing anymore
I wasn't I didn't mean yes I did say
that
but I literally meant I wasn't planning
but I've been problem solving
in terms of songwriting you know since I
began at age 13 and if I continued I
would continue to problem solve in the
same way but I really thought if I want
to
I'm not terribly interested in
continuing to problem solve that way
yeah I could but every time I
I I
set out on a on a project it's going to
take about three years that's my usual
thing and I thought I don't know do I
want to spend three years doing this or
would I rather spend it
looking around the world while I still
have the chance and see as much and I
thought yeah I'd rather do that so I
didn't have any pressing desire to write
but this this dream
aside from how
what a strong impression it made it sort
of came in the same cycle it was about
three years after the last so that cycle
seems to be part of my
creative system
yeah and it it seems to have a life of
its own
yeah that's my that's that's my rhythm
I'm grateful for it I really enjoy it
when it happens yeah and when it's not
going on
uh well I think it's always going on
right but when it's not going on I used
to think oh I have writer's block I
can't write but no actually what's going
on is something something deep and
subconscious
is working and it will manifest itself
at a certain point and I'll say ah
I feel like writing this all right it's
still in motion that three-year period
because I just started to write
recently you've started again yeah I've
wrote written two songs Yeah you
mentioned before the the your hearing
problems which have are they how is that
now by the way
it's not getting better it's not no
when did it start
about two years ago two and a half years
ago yeah
yeah and what did what did you notice
I started to lose a hearing in my left
ear and it eventually or it's at this
moment it's
yeah I think eight percent Hearing in
that ear really uh I'm hopeful that
something can be
something can be done but uh but I'm
starting to
get used to the fact that maybe nothing
nothing could be done I can still hear
well enough to play guitar and write
yeah but I can't hear well enough to
play with
five or six musicians
and sing and in a big space
with a lot of noise it's it's a
it's a confusion
maybe that's fine maybe it's a maybe
there's something to be
learned from that or what do you think
that would be
I have to see what it is acceptance of
you know less
you have less and you have to make do
with less
that would be true for everybody yeah
so it could be it could be that the most
frustrating thing is
I really took it for granted that I
could do this thing which is here very
well
hear sound very well
and uh I wonder when it went away I was
you know I was frustrated I was angry
and I still I could go there but
there's not there's no use to go there's
no use to go there I imagine that must
be a complicated conversation that
you've had to go through in your own
head
about all that it is
yeah and you probably feel different
about it different days
laughs
no I feel pretty much the same about it
which is like uh you know I'm just not
not happy about it you did play Newport
last summer yeah things got worse since
then yeah
then I could still hear enough if I had
speakers over here but now I can't yeah
do you think that might be kind of your
last big performance
well I hope not yeah
I hope not I really wanted to do the to
perform the seven Psalms yeah
and possibly I I could because it's a
simple piece with a guitar yeah and uh
kind of percussion instrument so it's
that's possible even though I wrote and
played the guitar on this I I couldn't
even if a hearing was
fine I I couldn't play it and sing it at
the same time at the guitar is too
complicated for me to
be able to concentrate on My Singing and
telling storytelling and play this so I
need somebody else so I'll try that this
week and see what I see what I find out
I haven't given up hope but uh but I'm
prepared if uh to accept that I might
not be able to
oh I want to go back to the to seven
Psalms and just and the lyrics somewhat
because a couple of people on hearing
the album made comparisons to Bowie's
black star and Leonard Cohen's you want
it darker those ended up being their
last albums obviously but well
if that's if that's the point of the
of the
critics response to it I think well you
didn't really get what I'm doing you
know this is not about this being a last
album or
my mortality or something this was a
piece that
you know came
from quite quite naturally
wait and uh
I didn't think of it as well this will
be my last album and so
maybe it will be but you know
I don't know I just saw Willie Nelson do
a big concert at age 90. yeah so uh
I don't know I hope it's not because I
enjoy making records and I
and as I said I I'm I just wrote not
just but I've written two two songs so
I imagine I could make it make another
another record and I don't know how long
but as long as as long as I
as long as I can write and sing I'll
I'll make records even if it's just for
myself yeah you describe it as an
argument you're having with yourself
about belief or not well I think
I think that that's
you know I think that that's true
um
I don't set out to to address
any issue or point when I write they it
emerges yeah in the writing and I say oh
I see I see what I'm I see what this
song's about
and that kept coming up
in the songs in one way one way or
another
uh
I mean one of the songs
your forgiveness it's called
and it actually addresses that and
in the verses the verses are I have my
reasons to doubt and then the choruses
dip your hand in Heaven's Waters God's
imagination all of life's abundance and
a drop of condensation then it goes to I
have my reasons to doubt but I ended
that song purposefully with the dip your
hand in Heaven's water so
I'm balancing out and saying well I'll
yeah I I understand my
that there are reasons to doubt but I'm
going to come down on
the other the other side
I like it more
um
there's so many striking lines in this
music but there's one in love is like a
braid
you say
I lived a life of pleasant Sorrows until
the real deal came
yeah uh
I think
uh
if you have a real tragedy in your life
it makes mild depression seem like a
pleasant sorrow it almost seems like an
Indulgence yeah you could feel like oh I
just feel
I just don't I'm not happy but then
something really bad happens some
tragedy that's
that's really bad yeah but several
people have said to me
I've said I really like that line I
lived a life of pleasant Sorrows until
the real deal came and what they meant
what they heard was and then
I really got love
I really fell in love with someone
that isn't what I intended right to me
but it can mean that I
I've said said this before but I I am
convinced that the listener completes
the song yeah what they hear is the
meaning of what that song is once it
leaves my yeah you know my laboratory
then it belongs to everybody else to to
make of it whatever they want and that's
the truth I have my own version of what
the truth is but another another version
of it may very well be more interesting
or accurate than than what I think the
songs are if the songs are
good enough or flexible enough they can
mean
you could there are there are several
possible interpretations to it yeah
does the meaning of songs over time
ever change for you it does change yeah
uh that's a very interesting question or
an interesting observation
The Sound of Silence
the way I performed it at Newport is a
very different song Than The Sound of
Silence the way that was a number one
record in 1966 yeah
it's aged into another
another feeling and another meaning and
there are quite a few of my older songs
that that have that seem to have aged
well yeah no uh
um let's see Homeward Bound yeah
that that that that has some other
Dimension to it that that it didn't have
what's what's the dimension it has now
do you think
well uh
when I was a kid it was I was on the I
was just traveling
as a singer and
and it was about coming home to to my
girlfriend you know now it feels like
it could all
I've sung it up memorials yeah
it's a bigger home
that that we're going to as a songwriter
how does it feel to see one of your
songs evolve like that yeah very
gratifying yeah I I would have no way of
knowing when I was
27 or 28 years old that bridge over
troubled water would be
I I didn't know that it would last for
50 years or something
um
so yeah some songs take on a life and
they they
they're still relevant in their form
like the Rhiannon giddens version of
American Tune where we changed I rewrote
two of the lines for her in that song
um and
it becomes power it becomes powerful
again it's powerful because it's sung by
a woman it's powerful because it's sung
by an African-American yeah
um
so
it takes on a different meaning than
when I sing it yeah
just as valid a meaning but maybe it
becomes more powerful because you
haven't heard it in that
placed in that context yeah
it is interesting when the song gets a
whole new dimension like yeah absolutely
as as you mentioned a lot of people
looked at this and thought you were
writing about mortality and you say
you're not
but it's in here I mean it appears to be
in here well it is yeah it's it's part
of the discussion yeah but outside of
that discussion if you're asking me do I
personally think about that subject yeah
inwardly inordinately no I don't of
course I'm 81 years old of course I I
think about it but I mean is it pressing
on me no it's not yeah so when you write
weight for example
what are you thinking when those words
oh yeah weight is definitely about that
subject but it's the final song and the
piece yeah you know and we we've arrived
at a place where it's my instinct tells
me it's appropriate to discuss this this
subject now yeah it's gonna it's going
to be the final song on the piece and
the pieces then I decided I was going to
end that with amen right so that really
says this is the end of the
33-minute seven Psalms piece
is is them is there some part
in the whole process
that gives you the most satisfaction
um
I'm not sure that there's that there's
one part
I like the music part more than the the
words you do
it's easier
it comes easier to me
and the words are
yeah you have to struggle more more with
words
um
but
when when my songs are reviewed
most of the reviews are about the lyrics
yeah because if you were because writers
yeah
it's hard to write about
music about sound but it's much easier
to take a line and say
what did that mean or he's thinking
about this or something
but the the ineffable is me is music
because what is it it's some kind of
sound and then you're
you're moved by it rhythmically or
harmonically or melodically that's a
mystery that's a great mystery I want to
go back to this question that I was
asking before which was when you talked
about retiring
from performing
um
and you said you said in one interview
it's an act of courage to let go
because you kind of I think your wording
was I I will have to see who I am
or am I just this person who defined by
what I do
you remember that
no but sounds like me okay but I was
wondering if how
in that if you if you recall going
through that process at all and and
where you sort of found yourself
well what happened was
now I don't have the option to go and
perform you know now I really really
wanted to
now like now I can't and I I you know I
was
but I know why I I I know why I said
that
I had have been doing that version of my
live show
for long enough that I had developed
or changed the the
arrangements and the and the order and
change the show to the point where I
thought
that's complete that's complete now I'm
not going to make any better choices you
can tell when when musicians are not
interested in what they're playing even
if they're playing the right notes yeah
that's not right you know so when it's
not right you have to you have to stop
or else you're a hack yeah
you didn't want to be a hacker I don't
want to be a hack no
do you think about your legacy at all no
not important
no
not important no
but what would you like for your music I
guess
I feel about the music is like
if it lives it deserves it if it doesn't
live it didn't deserve it the purpose of
this is of the music in terms of the
culture is to nourish the culture
there's always a source of nourishment
and if you're
privilege is enough to be that source
for a certain period of time it's a
privilege but it's not if you're not
you could be disappointed personally but
the culture doesn't care yeah they're
fine so then if you say well I'm fine
too you know
either way either way